in this video I want to talk about the
lac operon cap site and Khattab light
repression so before we can discuss this
topic we have to think about cyclic a
and P and its importance in this system
so cyclic a and P is a signal of hunger
for the prokaryote so this signal of
hunger cyclic a and P has to be related
to the amount of glucose around so if a
pro if you're hungry does that mean that
you have glucose or that you need
glucose so if you're hungry you probably
you want to eat right you want glucose
so that means if you're hungry you have
low glucose so Sigma K and P if is a
bunch of it as a bunch of the hunger
signal that means you have little
glucose around and I'm saying you just
to make things a little bit simpler and
easier to relate to but this is keep it
- for prokaryotes now if you have a low
cyclic AMP e a low amount of the hunger
signal that probably means you already
have glucose available or the prokaryote
has glucose available now why cyclic a
and B important if cyclic a and P is
present that means that there's low
glucose levels okay cyclic GMP is
present it will bind CA P now CA P is
the protein that binds cyclic AMP e so
it's a cyclic AMP e binding protein so
if C cyclic AMP e is around it will bind
the cyclic GMP binding protein and form
the cyclic GMP cap complex ok I'm going
to call it the camp cap complex what
does this complex do what it does is it
binds the cap site on the lac operon and
when it does that it activates
transcription of the structural genes of
the lac operon okay so let's see how
this would work now we have to consider
the availability of glucose and lactose
when we think about this so there are
four different scenarios the first one
with when there is glucose and no
lactose second when there's neither and
the third when there's both and the last
when there's only lactose so what's
going on here what we're going to do is
think about the sugar presence being
related to the proteins bound to the
operon and whether or not
transcription of the structural genes
would occur so notice I've drawn glucose
here and I've boxed it in orange and the
reason why is because this portion here
this cyclic AMP II and cap protein
complex as also boxed in orange because
the availability of glucose tells you
about whether this protein will be
available and bound to the operon and
then the lactose and the repressor are
both circled in blue because they're
related and knowing about the presence
of lactose will tell you about whether
or not the repressor protein is bound so
let's think about this first scenario
the prokaryote has glucose available but
no lactose so if glucose is available
what does that tell you about cyclic a
and P levels well if there's lots of
glucose that means you have low cyclic a
and P so I'll write that here low cyclic
a and P if there's low cyclic a and P
what does that mean about this protein
will it be bound to the cap site well no
right because if there's no cyclic AMP e
that complex won't form this complex
will not form it there's no cyclic a and
P around so will not bind the cap site
what about lactose availability if
there's no lactose what does that mean
about the repressor protein is it going
to be bound or not well lactose induces
the repressor protein to fall off but if
there's no lactose that means the
repressor protein will be bound so
that's drawn here the repressor protein
is down to the operator but there's no
cyclic A&P cap complex balanced to the
cap site notice that because this
repressor is here
transcription will not occur RNA
polymerase here bound to the promoter is
blocked so could or would transcription
occur no and does that make sense let's
think about that for a second if the
prokaryote has glucose available to it
why would it need to make the enzymes
that break down lactose it wouldn't need
to write on top of that on top of that
the there's no lactose around anyway so
even if there was lactose there you
wouldn't need to break it down because
this glucose around so
the first thing is that because this
this protein this complex here is not
down there the activation is not the
activation of transcription is not going
to happen so there's no activator bound
okay and the second thing is of course
that there's a repressor around so
there's no activator bound oops
there's no activator bound and the
repressor is bound so transcription
would definitely not occur what about
the second scenario in which there's no
glucose and no lactose well if there's
no glucose that means that you're hungry
right or that the prokaryote is hungry
so that means high sleep with JMP high
cyclic A&P levels so will the cyclic AMP
ECAP complex form yes it will form and
it will bind and that's why it's drawn
here bound now there's no lactose around
so no lactose no inducer that means that
the repressor protein is going to be
bound so the repressor protein is bound
here because in there's no lactose
available to induce it to fall off so
will transcription occur here no again
it's blocked by that repressor so
although although it is activated here
the although the activator is present it
is activated the repressor is bound so
the repressor blocks that RNA polymerase
so in this case you can imagine that's a
really really bad scenario for the
prokaryote because there's no glucose
brand available for energy and there's
no lactose available for energy they
have no nothing to break down for energy
so they're desperate for energy in this
point which is why they activate this in
hopes that maybe if there's lactose
around they can break it down for energy
but even then there's no lactose so that
repressor is there what about this third
scenario the third scenario here is when
we have when the prokaryote has glucose
and lactose both available so if there's
glucose around that means that what
about the cyclic AMP e levels it means
the cyclic AMP e levels are low so we
have low cyclic a and P levels
that means that there's no hunger signal
so no hunger signal means and and no
cyclic a and P I mean this complex will
not form and it won't bind to the cap
sight what about the repressor protein
will it be bound
well there's lactose available so it
induces that repressor to to fall off so
the repressor will not be bound so
notice here the K the cyclic AMP II cap
site is not our camp complex is not
bound to the cap site and the repressor
is not bound to the operator so could
transcription occur here the answer is
it could but it probably won't know now
that's a little funny answer right why
would that be the case well the first
thing is that there's no repressor right
so um so it can go the RNA polymerase
can go but it's not activated here the
cipa KP cap complex is not here so I
will put here that it's activated
because that which is me it's not
activated sorry my mistake
it is not activated even though there's
no repressor bound now what is what's
going on here why does this make sense
or what's going on at all
well there is locked us around right so
it could go ahead and transcribe these
genes or break lactose down but glucose
is around right so glucose just goes
through glycolysis and boom done the the
cell or the the prokaryote has energy so
there's no need to tap on lactose in
this case so that's the idea there
there's no need to tap on lactose for
energy because glucose available because
glucose is available what about
last case the last case is when there's
no glucose and there is lactose so no
glucose means that the hunger signal
will be around there's high high cyclic
AMP e hisis if K and P so this complex
will form and it will be bound there it
is and the their presence of lactose is
yes there is lactose so it will induce
the repressor to fall off so there's no
repressor there so now the RNA
polymerase is bound and activated so in
this case transcription can occur so in
this case the answer is yes
transcription will occur because the the
two scenarios one is that it's activated
and there's no repressor so it's active
and not blocked and that makes sense
right this is the case in which there's
no glucose around for energy but there's
lactose so because there's lactose and
there's no glucose then it makes sense
then that you would go ahead or the
prokaryote would go ahead and transcribe
these genes that could break down
lactose for energy because it has no
other choice there's no about there's no
glucose available I hope that video was
helpful in understanding this idea one
last thing I am a tutor if you live in
Southern California feel free to contact
me via email at move University at
gmail.com see the description below for
more details thanks for watching